[Music]
you look amazing how much fun is it to
be here thank you so much it's so much
fun to be here tonight I figured this
dress was fun and teen choice it's
mosquito and you're in the middle of
filming right now right where we're just
starting so I've been training so I
spent a lot of time covering the bruises
on my shin the training but it's a good
thing it's a good thing because that
means we're getting back in the swing of
things and it's sort of exciting for our
season finale airs tomorrow and then we
start shooting almost immediately season
three so I don't have to have much time
without shadow hunters in my life and
that makes me very happy
that is amazing anything you can tell us
what you're filming right now what can
you tease for what sir I don't know much
about season three yet the show is
definitely continuing to mature and we
saw a lot of maturity in season two and
that's gonna continue moving forward in
season three but I can tell you our
season finale tomorrow night is
absolutely I think it's brutal
we have there were actually teasing that
a major character dies in the finale
episode so we'll see grab a box of
tissues and your favorite comfort food
because you're gonna need it so I can't
wait for you guys to find out who it is
maybe a little bit more than one death
but I'm gonna get in trouble for saying
that but it's gonna be super exciting
and and I can't wait for season 3 your
lovely co-star just used the word quote
brutal about the finale
yeah I mean even though you guys some of
you guys have read the books you're not
gonna expect this one up until this
point you know the shadow world that
Claire is been in has been very magical
and full of wonder and almost kind of a
wonderland of sorts and in this episode
we've seen in the last few episodes as
well but this one especially she starts
to really see the brutal cold deadly
side of the shadow world
[Music]
you